غاب التفاؤل الذي ظهر خلال بعض الفترات
السنه الماضيه بشان امكانيه احياء الاتفاق
النووي الايراني واصبح تبادل الاتهامات
الامر الوحيد الذي يذكر بهذا الاتفاق
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا وبريطانيا
والمانيا اتهمت الحكومه الايرانيه بعدم
الوفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه حظر
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه وقالت ان ايران
عدلت سرا نظام العمل في منشاه فوردو
لانتاج اليورانيوم عالي التخسيب واضافت ان
انتاج يورانيوم عالي التخسيس فوردو يحمل
مخاطر كبيره مرتبطه بالانتشار النووي دون
وجود اي مبررات مقنعه للاستخدام المدني
ردا على هذه الاتهامات قال كبير المفاوضين
الايرانيين عن باقر ان طهران التزمت
بتعهداتها وتتوقع ان تتعامل الاطراف
الاخرى بنفس الطريقه واكد باقي لي ان
تطورات الاتفاق النووي اثبتت طهران ان
عدوها ليس جديرا بالثقه هذا الجدل بين
الدول الغربيه بدا بعد تقرير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ذكر ان السلطات
الايرانيه ربطت بين مجموعتين من اجهزه
الطرد المركزي في منشاه فودو لتخسيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 60 في المئه دون ان تخبر
الوكاله اغضب تقرير الوكاله ايران وقال
رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذري الايرانيه محمد
سلامي ان السلوك مدير الوكاله الدوليه
غير محترف ومرفوض ولا يليق بمكانه الوكاله
اعتبرت ايران ان ما جاء في تقرير وكاله
الدوليه بني على خطا احد مفتشيها الذي قدم
لها معلومات غير دقيقه واعترف لاحقا بانه
اخطا يبدو ان مستوى الثقه متدني ايضا بين
ايران والوكاله الدوريه للطاقه الذريه ما
يعقد امكانيه اخراج مفاوضات احياء الاتفاق
النووي من حاله الجمود حاله الجمود التي
عبر عنها الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في وقت
سابق بالقول ان الاتفاق النووي ميت لكن لا
يمكن الاعلان ذلك جون كيربي المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي علق لاحقا على
كلام بايدن بالقول انه يعبر عن موقف
الاداره الامريكيه التي لا تعتبر الاتفاق
النووي اولويه حاليا اذا فاحياء الاتفاق
النووي ليس من الاولويات الان على الاقل
بالنسبه لواشنطن وهذا كاف لاستبعاد التوصل
الى اتفاق قريبا